هذه التطورات التي تاتينا تباعا من قطاع
غزه حيث افاد مراسل الجزيره قبل قليل
باستشهاد اربعه واصابه اخرين معظمهم اطفال
ونساء في قصر في قصف اسرائيلي استهدف روضه
اطفال تؤوي نازحين في منطقه الزوايده وسط
قطاع غزه وبحسب الدفاع المدني فان عددا من
المفقودين ما يزال تحت
الانقاض
يا
[موسيقى]
شباب ايدها رجلها يا اخوي
رجلها
معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هاني الشاعر
هاني ما اخر
المستجدات نعم عثمان في الرساله السابقه
كنا نتحدث عن هدوء نسبي في رفح لكن الان
نتحدث عن عدد من الاستهدافات الاسرائيليه
طالت منزلين احدا هم في خربه العدس حتى
اللحظه جرى نقل شهيدين من هذا المنزل
واصابه اخرين وهنا من خلفي في المستشفى
الكويتي يصل على الاقل ثلاثه من الشهداء
الاطفال وعدد من الجرحى جر قصف منزل يبعد
عن هذه المنطقه نحو 200 متر فقط هذه
الغاره كانت غاره عنيفه طالت هذا المنزل
دون سابق انذار ادت هذه الغاره الى ثلاثه
من الشهداء الاطفال وعدد من المصابين الان
يجري تحويل هؤلاء المصابين من هذا المشفى
الى مشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف النجار كون هذا
المشفى مشفى صغير يختص بشكل رئيس في
استقبال وتقديم الاسعاف الاولي للمصابين
ومن ثم تحويلهم الى مشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف
النجار او الى المشفى الاوروبي في خان
يونس اذا ثلاث غارات متزامنه على منزلين
هنا في مدينه رفح بالقرب من المشفى
الكويتي وفي منطقه خربه العدس طواقم
الاسعاف حتى اللحظه التي هرعت الى هذه
المنازل ما تزال تعمل في المكان الى جانب
طواقم الدفاع المدني بمساعده من المواطنين
يحاولون تحت انقاذ هذه البنايات التي قصفت
قبل قليل دون سابق انذار من قبل الطيران
الحربي لاسرائيل في المنطقه الوسطى
والمنطقه الشماليه من مدينه رفح كما
اسلفنا سابقا كان هناك حاله من الهدوء لكن
الطارات كانت تحلق على علو منخفض وهذا كان
مؤشر واضح على ان هذه الطائرات قد تقوم
بشن مزيدا من الغارات الجويه هنا على
مدينه رفح خاصه مع حلول ساعات الليل كما
اعتدنا تزداد نسبه الغارات الجويه وحدتها
على هذه المدينه التي تشهد منذ نحو خمسه
او سته ايام تكثيفا للغارات الجويه التي
تطال منازل السكنيه سواء في المنطقه
الغربيه او المنطقه الجنوبيه او المنطقه
الوسطى او المنطقه الشرقيه من مدينه رفح
التي لها خصوصيه مختلفه عن بقيه المناطق
عثمان سيما انها تاوي مئات الاف النازحين
فاقل غاره جويه هنا تطال منزلا او محيطه
تؤدي الى عدد كبير من الشه دا عدا ال
الجرحى لان اماكن مقتضى ممتلئه سواء
بالخيام المنازل ممتلئه بالنازحين اضعاف
الاعداد التي تتواجد كالعاده داخل هذه
المنازل معظم من اووا الى هذه البيوت هم
من مدينه خان يونس والمنطقه الوسطى
والشمالي قطع غزه هنا ايضا كما تستمعون
لمركبات الاسعاف التي ما تزال تتحرك وهي
تعطي مؤشر الى مواصله نقل مزيدا من
الشهداء والمصابين من المنازل التي قصفت
قبل قليل من قبل الط الحربي الاسرائيلي
هنا في مدينه رفح جنوب قطاع غزه في
المنطقه الوسطى ايضا كانت هناك عدد من
الغارات احداها طالت منزلا في مدينه دير
البلح وسط قطاع غزه وادت الى استشهاد
فلسطينيه على الاقل واصابه اخرين فضلا عن
ذلك استشهد فلسطينيين اثنين على الاقل
واصيب اخرين في قصف روضه للاطفال في منطقه
الزوايده الواقعه في المنطقه الوسطى من
قطاع غزه في خانيونس ايضا قصف مدفعي قبل
قليل وتسمع اصوات انفجارات بين الحين
والاخر في المنطقه الجن بيه وكذلك المنطقه
الغربيه نذكر بالاخبار التي تصل الينا
تباعا وهي هنا من مدينه رفح خمسه من
الشهداء على الاقل جلهم من الاطفال جرى
قصف منزلين احداهما في خربه العدس شمالي
مدينه رفح والاخر في القرب من المشفى
الكويتي هنا في وسط مدينه رفح جنوبي قطاع
غزه ونقل عشرات من المصابين الى المستشفى
الكويتي ومشفى الشهيد ابو يوسف النجار لا
احصائيه دقيقه حتى هذه اللحظه وهي مرشحه
بكل تاكيد للزياده في ظل هذه الغارات
المتواصله والتحليق المكثف للطيران الحربي
الاسرائيلي دائما ربما ما تتعمد اسرائيل
تكثيف غاراتها في ساعات الليل لايقاع اكبر
كم ربما من الخسائر البشريه كما هو واضح
لان الناس بيكونوا مجتمعين بالاحرى ويكون
في نوم عميق في هذه اللحظات تحديدا
وبالتالي الغارات عندما تصيب هذه المنازل
وتستهدف بشكل مباشر توقع خسائر بشريه
كبيره على الاضرار اليه هنا وفق معلومات
وصلت الينا لا مكان يؤون اليها على
الاطلاق يعني انت الان مثلا تتحدث عن يعني
قصف منزلين والناس نيام في ساعات في ساعات
الليل والشهداء من ال من الاطفال ليس هناك
مكان اي مكان يمكنهم ان يذهبوا ويوا
اليه هذا صحيح عثمان يعني عندما لجا الناس
هنا الى رفح كانوا قد يعني اعتقدوا بانها
منطقه امنه لكن اليوم هذه الاحداث
التي توقع هذه الخسائر الكبيره البشريه
تؤكد بعكس وزيف الروايه الاسرائيليه التي
قالت سابقا بانها بان رفح منطقه امنه وهذه
الغارات تاتي متزامنه مع التلويح
الاسرائيلي حول امكانيه القيام بعمل عسكري
في هذه المدينه وبكل تاكيد هذه المدينه
تاوي نحو مليون و2 ال على الاقل من
النازحين من خارج مدينه رفح اتوا على
دفعات سواء من خانيونس من المنطقه الوسطى
من مدينه غزه من منطقه الشمال حتى قبل
ساعات من الان نزح البعض من منطقه مواس
خان يونس الى مدينه رفح بعد ان تقدمت بشكل
مفاجئ بعض الاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
الى منطقه المواص الواقعه غربي مدينه خان
يونس هنا في مدينه رفح لها خصوصيه كما
استلفنا سابقا لان معظم الطرقات معظم
الاحياء معظم المنازل في محيطها في فنائها
اقيمت خيام والاعداد الان حتى داخل
المنازل هي اعداد مضاعفه وبالتالي عندما
ما تحدث غاره هنا تكون النتيجه بشكل طبيعي
هي مزيد من الضحايا مزيد من المصابين مزيد
من الدمار ايضا في المنازل التي تقصف لان
الغارات التي تشنها اسرائيل بكل تاكيد هي
غارات تدميريه تحدث دمار كبير عدا الخسائر
البشريه نحن نتحدث عن شهداء يسون اشلاء
وهذا يؤكد حتى ان طبيعه الغارات والصواريخ
المستخدمه في هذه ال عمليات القصف هذه هي
صواريخ تؤدي الى ايقاع اكبر عدد من
الشهداء و وكذلك الجرحى واحداث تدمير كبير
حتى في منازل مجاوره راينا قبل قليل وصول
لمصابين حتى من منازل تبعد عشرات الامتار
عن المنازل المستهدفه من قبل الطيران
الحربي الاسرائيلي الذي عاده ما يباغت
المنازل في هذه الساعه تحديدا ومع انتصاف
الليل وساعات الفجر الاولى تزداد وتيره
هذه الغارات في هذه المدينه التي ربما هي
على موعد مع عدوان اسرائيلي جديد هذه
الليله بعد ان شهدت الليالي الماضيه عدوان
مماثل طال منازل السكنيه في منطقه تل
السلطان وفي وسط مدينه رفح ومنطقه مخيم
لعوت واليوم خربت العدس عدا قصف منطقه
الحدود مع مصر هذا تصعيد واضح من قبل قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ياتي متزامنا كما
اسلفنا سابقا مع تلويح اسرائيلي بامكانيه
القيام بعمل عسكري في هذه المدينه
والتحذيرات الجديه من ان القيام باي عمل
عسكري يشكل خطوره كبيره هنا على سكان هذه
المدينه والنازحين اليها لان هذه المدينه
تحمل خصو مختلفه عن بقيه مناطق قطاع غزه
لانها تشكل ماوى لمعظم النازحين من مختلف
مناطق قطاع غزه وهم يعانون الامرين بفعل
ضيق وعدم اتساع المساحات هنا في هذه
المدينه لاستيعاب هذا الكم الكبير من
النازحين والان هؤلاء الذين هربوا من
الموت من مناطق خانيونس وغزه والشمال
يواجهون بالقتل هنا بفعل هذه الغارات
وكانهم هربوا من الموت الى الموت هكذا
توصل الرساله طبعا اسرائيل عبر هذه
الغارات المتواصله هنا ايضا تصل مركبه
وواضح ان مزي من المصابين والشهداء
مازالوا يصرون الى هذا المشفى